what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we know how many
episodes Jonathan Majors is going to
appear in for Loki season 2. however
it's not exactly what people think there
isn't going to be just one variant of
Kang the Conqueror in Loki season 2 but
there could be multiple we know there's
going to be at least two but there could
be three depending on what happens with
Jonathan majors in his trial most people
know by now that Jonathan Majors a few
months ago was arrested he was arrested
in New York City on domestic violence
charges and the trial was supposed to
begin this past Wednesday however it has
been pushed to September 15th next
Friday this should be the official start
of the trial in which Jonathan majors
and his legal team state that he is
innocent in this situation and he is in
fact the victim and they have provided a
lot of evidence so far to prove this but
of course nothing is ever official until
a jury or judge decides the biggest
thing is that Marvel Studios and Disney
have kept completely quiet about the
situation whereas other agencies and
Studios have dropped Jonathan Majors he
has been losing work and he lost his
management company and his PR Company
but Disney has remained silent however
that could be because they already have
a plan in place to replace Jonathan
Majors if he is indeed found guilty in
court so today we'll talk about what
we'll call Marvel's backup plan is as
it's been revealed how many episodes
that Jonathan Majors Victor timely or
Kang or King variant will be in Loki
season 2. and if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner picks one
item and we pick a winner at the end of
each month so we've got a new report
today from The Hollywood Reporter
stating that Jonathan Majors will appear
in about half of the Loki season 2 shows
well we know that there is going to be
six episodes in total so about half is
three now we've heard from some insiders
before that he might be appearing in
four which could be the case but for now
since The Hollywood Reporter has come
out and stated he'll appear in half
we'll assume he's going to be in three
but like I mentioned this isn't exactly
going to be what everybody thinks it's
not just going to be Victor timely who
shows up Victor timely is a variant of
Kang the one that we have seen in all of
the promos and trailers for Loki season
2 and make no mistake he is indeed a
variant of King the Conqueror he is
still Nathaniel Richards which is Kang's
original name and it sounds like he is
indeed going to be the True Villain of
this show however another variant of
King is reportedly going to enter the
show as well and that is he who remains
now if you recall he who remains was in
Loki season one he's who Sylvie and Loki
met at the end he is the one who created
the TVA and controls the sacred timeline
and basically keeps the Multiverse in
check and he told Sylvie and Loki if
they killed him his variance would be
Unleashed and that is exactly what
happened well apparently according to
several different insiders actually he
is going to be returning in Loki season
2 and we're actually unsure if he's
going to be returning as a villain or a
good variant of King the Conqueror so
when The Hollywood Reporter reports that
Jonathan Majors is going to appear in
about half of the episodes that doesn't
just mean he'll appear as only Victor
timely but he could possibly appear as
another variant of Kang in fact it
sounds like he will now remember he who
remains he ended the multiversal war
before he defeated all of the other
kanks then created the sacred timeline
then created the TVA to keep Branch
timelines from creating other king the
conquerors and then maintained it and
essentially he saved the universe so
he's not exactly bad he did everything
he could to keep the Multiverse from
being destroyed now we're unsure if this
is going to be the exact same character
in the comics can can transfer his
Consciousness into another different
variant sometimes so could this be the
exact same King that we saw at the end
of Loki season one yes it could be is it
we are unsure he has been described as
benevolent by some insiders which means
he is peaceful good and that is kind of
how the old he who remains was he did
what was necessary to keep the peace of
the Sacred timeline but here's the
kicker there could actually be another
variant appearing and this will depend
on what happens with Jonathan Majors you
see right now A lot of people are pretty
surprised that we're seeing so much
promotion for Victor timely showing
Jonathan Majors himself in all of these
Loki trailers and TV spots and
promotions it makes it seem like Marvel
has decided that they are going to keep
Jonathan majors in this role as king the
Conqueror especially because before for
the promotions for Loki season 2 and
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania they
avoided showing him and they avoided
saying the name King the Conqueror in
their description for Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania they simply just said
the villain or a threat so they went
from really kind of keeping a low
profile with Jonathan Majors 2 now
showing him a lot in the promos for Loki
season 2 which makes everybody believe
Marvel Studios is keeping him however we
have heard before that Marvel does have
a backup plan and of course that backup
plan is to replace him as king the
Conqueror and they could do that by
bringing in a different variant a
different variant of King the Conqueror
and apparently according to some sources
they did end up doing reshoots for Loki
season 2. and according to Insider Alex
P over from the cosmic circus we will
see what Marvel Studios decision is for
Jonathan majors at the end of Loki
season 2. so basically what it appears
that Marvel Studios has done is filmed
other scenes with another actor playing
a different variant of King the
Conqueror and that's the backup plan
they will only use this they will only
bring in this new actor and this new
very if Jonathan Majors is found guilty
Disney is honestly taking the right
approach when it comes to Jonathan
Majors whether he ends up being innocent
or guilty he is innocent until proven
guilty so firing him before he is
actually proven guilty and found guilty
by a court is really not cool because
what if he's innocent what if all of
this stuff was just used against him for
him to be the victim in this situation
then he got fired for nothing so if this
is true from what we've heard I do
respect this decision to wait and see
what happens in the trial and if he is
found guilty they will simply introduce
a new actor as a new variant of King the
Conqueror and use that actor moving
forward that is Marvel studios's backup
plan wait and see what happens in the
trial and like I've mentioned before in
a few videos and this is just
speculation on my part but Jonathan
majors and his legal team has probably
met with Kevin feige in Marvel Studios
and Disney and has showed them all of
the evidence to support his claim since
him and his legal team have been stating
from the beginning they are innocent and
they have proof so he's probably met
with them and said please just wait till
the trial we believe that this whole
thing's gonna blow over and I'm gonna be
found innocent so please don't make a
decision until after then and of course
Marvel Studio seems to have respected
that and said okay well wait but they
are preparing for the worst which they
should because if he is found guilty
they're not going to keep him they're
going to need somebody new to play King
the Conqueror and it looks like they
might have already found that person
filming new scenes for a new variant of
King however there is kind of a slight
issue arising if what we've heard is
true and they did film new scenes with a
new variant of king with a new actor
that means they're on a timeline now and
the trial for Jonathan Majors keeps
getting pushed back the trial will have
to end in a verdict and decision will
have to be reached by the court before
those episodes with the new actor air
and right now we're about a month away
from the start of Loki season 2 it
starts on October 6th so less than a
month and the trial doesn't start again
until September 15th and of course there
is the possibility that that could be
pushed back again as well now we do have
more time than that October 6th is only
the first episode the second and the
third will be on the 13th and the 20th
and if they were going to wait until the
very last episode to show a new actor
and new variant coming in then that
would be November 10th which is two
months away from now and that should be
enough time for the trial to actually
come to an end and in that case Marvel
could air the alternate episode that
they shot with a new Kang variant actor
so this is Marvel's backup plan if
Jonathan Majors is found guilty and
again I respect the way that they are
going about this I respect the fact that
they didn't just fire him move on with
the new actor before a decision is made
in court because if he is innocent then
he shouldn't be punished but of course
if he is found guilty they will have to
move on and they have a backup plan for
that so let me know what you think about
this in the comments down below and if a
new variant comes who do you think will
be do you think he'll just be just a
normal Kanga he who remains or somebody
else let us know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all the latest news you
can also follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf